and let's talk about this story out of
cleveland can we about
kevin porter jr okay this
reports are that the cavs are ready to
uh
trade him or wave him because he had a
tantrum the other night when he found
out that
his locker had been moved from where it
had been
in their locker room further away
um to make room for taurean prince
recently acquired in the trade
and uh not disrespectful the outburst
was
i don't care if you're the first man
12th man you can't move my locker
now without calling me and be like hey
we're going to move your stuff
and move it from one area first of all
there's personal things in there let's
start there
secondly like that is the ultimate sign
there's three things that is
the signs of respect for players they're
airy you know it is their area
their uniform number like all of a
sudden you come in like oh we gave you a
number to shock because we just well
whoa wait like that would be
disrespectful so that is a disrespect i
i i do agree with kevin
porter if you don't want the guy there
just don't have the guy there but you
can't
be mad at him for being upset that you
moved his life but we don't know what
was said
exactly i don't care what was said out
first yeah and he headed out
headed out with kobe altman the gm too
if anybody came to me after they did
that to me
we would have had it out like in that
moment even if you have not been with
the team all year long
friday night was the first time he'd
been with them come on man oh
oh now that changes it earlier yeah it
does a little bit
come on he's had some he's had some
personal stuff going on
has not played a game this year was with
the team
friday night and then this happened
after the game you know so ernie they
should have
like like kenny said they should have
called him and said hey you ain't been
here we don't know what you're going on
we wish you well come back when you're
ready
but we're going to move your locker to
the end of the bench because obviously
when you come back you know
why did they see this is the thing chuck
why did they move it
because they couldn't no no no there's
enough locker if they moved him to where
that guy was well
they could have had that
what's the reason that that changes it
though it that does change
why are you moving his locker well
because give rory and prince the locker
that he's giving that guy no
because because of covet they have less
lockers and he just got there and he
hadn't been there all season
that actually does change the argument
wait time out okay like well hold on
what is the code that's the rule we
can't because we can't be together
tori and prince being the locker that he
they gave him they don't
he did no no why couldn't tori and
prince take the locker that they moved
they needed it because he just got to
the team
are you listening to the question
they're part of it and part of that
listen to the questions part of it
has to do with nba seniority as well
listen no no all right hold it shot what
you're saying if the guy has not been
there all season
and they needed an extra locker because
of uh coveted protocols
they need an extra locker they move his
they took his locker and gave him
another locker further away and gave
tori and prince his life that doesn't
make sense because it was in the
building
exactly exactly there's a locker room
where i am you're going to move my stuff
into the fact that coach needed to talk
to
hey the coast needed to talk to tony and
prince exactly he didn't need to talk to
a guy
that's why he went he got crazy that's
why he went off on them and they would
have gone off on him
feeling had a feeling that story would
create some conversation you know that
happened to me
no that didn't happen you got the locker
problem so i came in and i picked the
locker and then when i came back
catman it was his terry catholic yeah
terry cavaliers he's like no
no not a young fellow that's my luck i
was like man go ahead and you gave him
his locker
you don't care exactly he's not there
let me tell you something i played with
cat bone
yeah philadelphia mississippi yeah one
of my favorite teams
from philadelphia mississippi okay yeah
old country boy we will uh we will take
a time
coming back if i ever come here my stuff
move it's gonna be some damn furniture
thank you